by the word of the lord were the heavens
made
and all the host of them by the breath
of his mouth
for he spake
and it was done
he commanded
and it stood forth so fast
for by him were all things created
that are in heaven and that are in earth
visible and invisible
whether they be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers all things were
created by him
and for him
and he is before all things
and by him
all things consist
god is good
and all the time
have you had a blessed day today
so have i and i sincerely and seriously
thank god for that and i hope that god's
people online have also been blessed by
the events that took place here i
received an
email or text from someone when i went
back to my home
between the sermon and lunch
and the person said i have been
following the revival at ramsey
i have decided to be re-baptized
and so we thank god for his word
we thank god for
the reach that technology has all over
the world that you and i can worship in
ramsey minnesota and someone in kenya
can make a decision for christ maybe
someone in china has made a decision for
god maybe someone in tanzania someone in
brazil has made a decision for god god
is good
and all the time
let me say to my friends online if
you're still wavering between god and
baal choose god
give your life to him make a decision
for him and make a decision to be
baptized
i will not hold you along this evening
we've had a long day and temperance must
apply to all things including preaching
but before i get into it as always be
sure to preserve reference in the
presence of god make sure these things
don't ring
favor number two while i'm speaking pray
for me and say lord put your words in
that man's mouth jeremiah chapter 1
verse 9 then the lord put forth his hand
and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth
and isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason
together in other words favor number
three let us think
our subject for this brief meditation is
decency is man-made what did i say
decency is man-made let us pray
our father and our god
you've been with us since september the
third be with us now
as we close off this week
of revival
give to me the words i need to speak
grant me the spirit of christ that i may
speak them with the proper attitude
grant me the spirit that i may have
insight into the words
and let that spirit give comprehension
to those listening
cleanse me for my sins dear god
let me just lean my full weight of trust
upon you because you will not move
i give myself to you as an instrument
use me regard and for anyone listening
who's still in the valley of decision
father let your spirit gently move that
person over the line to choose christ
if someone listening has covered 19 in
the name of christ who healed everyone
who came to him heal that person heal
those persons i pray now heal us
spiritually god in jesus name we pray
let god's people say amen and amen
matthew 16 reading from verse 13. it is
now 4 53 7 minutes to 5 i'll release it
by 5 15.
short and sweet
what book did i say matthew what chapter
16 what verse 13.
matthew 16 reading from verse 13 when
jesus came into the course of caesarea
philippi
he asked his disciples saying whom do
men say that i the son of man am
and they said
some say that thou were john the baptist
some
elias and others jeremiah or one of the
prophets
he saith unto them but whom say ye that
i am
and simon peter answered and said
thou are the christ
the son of the living god
and jesus answered and said unto him
blessed are thou simon barjona for flesh
and blood hath not revealed unto thee
but my father
which is in heaven
peter said
thou art the christ
the son of the living god
christ means anointed
so peter is saying you're the one of
whom the old testament spoke you are the
one sent prophesied of in the old
testament you are the anointed one thou
art the christ then he said the son of
the living god
go to john chapter five as we try to
understand what peter meant by son of
the living god even though peter himself
may not understood because this was a
revelation from the father
john 5
jesus healed a man who had been sick 38
years at the pool of bethesda
the man is restored he is happy he talks
to the pharisees they wanted to know who
healed him verse 14 afterward jesus
findeth him in the temple and said unto
him behold thou art made whole sin no
more lest the worst thing come unto thee
john 5 14 the man departed and told the
jews that it was jesus which had made
him whole
and therefore did the jews persecute
jesus and sought to slay him because he
done these things on the sabbath
but jesus answered them my father
worketh hitherto
and i work
that's verse 18 of john 5. notice the
words of christ my father worketh
hitherto and i work in other words god
has always been working from eternity up
to now and so have i
he's actually saying i am fully divine
i'm just like my father but but that's
what he was saying when he said my
father now the jews understood he meant
i am the son of god and therefore
therefore the jews sought them all to
kill him because he not only had broken
the sabbath but said also god was his
father making himself
equal with god
now
when jesus said i am the son of god what
was he saying
i am god
he wasn't saying i'm the father he's
saying i am god i am defined that's what
he's saying and the jews understood that
that's why they tried to kill him in
john 5 verse 18 and verse 15. now
15-16 let's go back to matthew 16 now
and listen to peter
and peace answers said
verse 16 thou art the christ the son of
the living god thou art the christ and
the son of the living god what peter is
saying
you are the anointed one and you are
also god whether peter understood that
or not now what am i trying to tell you
when jesus said blessed are thou simon
barjona for flesh and blood hath not
revealed unto thee but my father which
is in heaven and i say unto thee
verse 19 thou art peter and upon this
rock i will build my church and the
gates of hell shall not prevail against
it now
what did jesus mean by upon this rock i
will build my church
christ was referring to the statement
peter made when peter said thou art the
christ
the son of the living god
the church of god is built on the fact
that jesus christ
is god
it's not built on peter
because god from in heaven had to reveal
that to peter peter didn't know and so
jesus said his church is built on that
rock that rock is christ that frog is
the statement peter made that jesus is
the anointed one the christ and the son
of god he's divine so he's human he's
divine the church of god is built on the
fact that jesus christ is god and he's
also
human
peter spoke a word
listen to me carefully let me pray again
father continue to be with me please
that i may make this very simple
in jesus name amen
peter
spoke a word what was the word thou art
the christ
the son
of the living god
jesus said my church is built on that
word
what am i trying to tell you in this
brief devotion
the church of god
is built
on the word of god
of course christ himself is the word the
church of god is built on the word of
god i need to say it again now
jesus also said man shall not live by
bread alone but by every word that
proceedeth out of the mouth of god the
church of god is built on the word of
god and the inhabitants of that church
are to live their lives by the word of
god were members of the church
your church is built on the word
you and i are to live
by every word
question for you
don't answer me
do you make time for the word of god
i did not ask
do you own a bible
i asked
do you make time for the word of god
that which the church is built on and
that which we're supposed to live by
do we make time for the word of god if
we do not the times ahead will be so
trying we will be unable to make the
right decisions we will be unable to
stand for god because the power to stand
for god is the power in the very word of
god
listen to what the bible says
it's exactly five i have 15 minutes
in the beginning
god created the heaven and the earth
ella white writes
god
spoke
and his word
created his works in the natural world
bible commentary volume 1 page 1081
paragraph 1. god spoke
the word and his word
created his works in the natural world
what is she saying
the universe
is the result
of god's word but not what is she saying
what does the bible say
by the word of the lord
were the heavens made
on all the hosts of them by the breath
of his mouth psalm 33 verse 6 second
peter chapter 3 verse 5 for this they
willingly are ignorant of that by the
word of god the heavens will revolt and
the earth standing out of the water and
in the water the bible is clear the
entire universe is the result of god's
word
education page 126
paragraph four
what did i say
education
page 126.
paragraph four
listen carefully as you hold your bible
or your phone
the creative energy
that called the worlds into existence
is in the word of god
the power that made the universe is in
the word of god she goes on to say this
word imparts power it begets life
what does she mean by it begets life
well the bible says in genesis 1 24 and
god said let the earth bring forth grass
or first verse 11 of chapter one grass
is a living thing verse 24 let the earth
bring forth the living creature after
his kind living things came into
existence by the word of god
this word
has not lost its power
and so she goes on to say oh let me give
the entire quotation the creative energy
that called the worlds into existence is
in the word of god this word imparts
power it begets life every command is a
promise accepted by the will received
into the soul it brings with it the life
of the infinite one
what does that mean
it brings with it the life of the
infinite one the very life of god
mysteriously
it's in his word
it transforms the nature and recreates
the soul in the image of god to be
christ-like you cannot be christ-like
outside of the word of god
to make decisions that please god we
require the word of god the principles
of god's word this word
transforms the nature and recreates the
soul in the image of god
this is something i've said many times
and i will say it many times it's so
fundamental
we live in a universe
made by the word of god
it makes sense
to live
by what created the universe
what's our subject
decency
is man-made
why did i choose that let me pray dear
god
i ask one more time
speak through me please
in jesus name
amen
jesus said
as it was in the days of noah
so shall it be also in the days of the
son of man now listen
did it eat
they drank
they married wise they were given in
marriage
does that sound like a decent life
yes
this is what christ said about the days
of lord
luke 17 28 likewise also as it wasn't
theirs of luck they didn't eat
they drank they bought they sold they
planted their building
lost
i didn't mean to depress you you look
depressed
i just want you to think
you do not need god in order to live a
decent life
everything in order
tuition for the children and that's good
house almost paid off that's good
two cars that's good
secure job that's good
there is nothing wrong with that
on good terms with your neighbors that's
good moving up the ladder on the job
that's good about to complete your phd
that's good none of that is a sin but
i'm saying you can do all of that
without being converted
without having your nature changed
without being born again you can do that
to have the nature of christ you need to
be converted decency is man-made
conversion is god made
and conversion occurs
by this
i am appealing to you as your brother in
christ
your guest who has enjoyed your
hospitality
your sweet nature your kindness with a
capital k
all of that
will be of no avail in the judgment
if the word of god
is not your guide
your children will grow up to be decent
senators
and prime ministers and presidents and
ceos but if the word of god is not the
spinal cord of the spiritual structure
they will not be saved
decency
is man-made
a spiritual life
is god made and as verily as the
universe was made by the word the
universe of your personal life must be
made come on by the word of god
in revelation 19 verse 13 you don't need
to go there just listen
john has a vision of jesus christ coming
back to conquer his enemies and deliver
his people and he was clothed in a
vestige dipped with blood and his name
is called
the word of god
that's the name of jesus
jesus said john 14 6
i am the way
the truth
what is the truth jesus speaks again
john 17 17 sanctify them through thy
truth thy
word is truth
i'm calling upon you in the name of
jesus christ
in person and online
make time for the word of god
without this dwelling in your heart and
in your mind
situations will arise that will make it
impossible for you and me to make the
right decisions it has to be right in
the eyes of god it may be right in the
eyes of man but not in the eyes of god
for something to be right in the eyes of
god it must be based on thus saith the
lord
we're in troubles times
people have decisions to make
should i take a vaccine should i not
should i follow this mandate should i
not
all kinds of serious decisions have to
be made our guide must be thus saith the
lord and the thing about the word of god
the word of god is spirit filled you see
when you have the word you've got the
spirit
i didn't say when you have a bible in
your house i say when you have the word
you've got the spirit of god
and the spirit will tell you things that
are not explicitly written in god's word
decency
is man-made
conversion
is god made
and so i say unto you in the presence of
the holy god
the holy spirit and the holy angels no
matter what pressures you have in your
life make time
for the word of god this must be the
foundation stone on which you stand
and your family and your children
let me take a risk and say something
fairly harsh
if you have no interest in the word of
god
still teach it to your children
let them be saved
if you're too busy
to study for yourselves teach it to your
children i'm speaking to those of you in
person those on you online this is life
eternal that they might know thee and
how do you know god the word of god
and i closed a very familiar passage
psalm 105
119 verse 105 say it with me without
looking thy word is a
lamp unto my feet come on and a light
onto my path what does that mean i have
a decision to make
should i move to the country should i
move to this other city should i go back
to kenya should i move to australia i
have a decision to make which path
should i take thy word is a lamp unto my
feet
and the light unto my path
i thank god for your phd
i thank god for your masters he gave you
the brain
i thank god for your bachelors i thank
god for your postdoctoral degrees your
certificate from some intergalactic
institute of higher learning i thank god
for that but let me tell you this alone
will guide you correctly somebody say
amen this alone and so let me close
you've got the point i'm trying to make
decency for now tell me
is man-made
a christian life is god made
decency does not require conversion
a spiritual life
requires that one be transformed by the
word of god and let me give you the
words from god's faithful servant once
again education page 126 paragraph four
the creative energy that called the
worlds into existence is in the word of
god this word imparts power it begets
life every command is a promise accepted
by the will receive into the soul it
brings with it the life of the infinite
one it transforms the nature and
recreates the soul in the image of god
and this was god's original will when he
said let us make man how in our image
this is the power that transforms you
into god's image
all right rights and desire of ages not
desire of ages great controversy page
509 i believe this paragraph two many a
man
of cultured intellect and pleasing
manners
who would not stoop to what is commonly
regarded as an immoral act
is but a polish instrument in the hands
of satan
what is she saying here is an educated
man or woman
very cultured
direct bereft of this
and all that person is
is an instrument in the hands of satan
how many of you
want to be in the hands of god can i see
your hands i believe you
stand up with me
we are seven of the adventists
i thought i'd get one amen but i didn't
we are seventh-day adventists
we are people of the book
the sun will set in
about two hours
and the holy day
will pass
our holiness
does not pass
are you with me
and this is something i say very often
the sun sets on a day
the sun does not set on our holiness
whatever holiness we have i'm saying
that to say this because saturday night
is about to come
do not regard saturday night as so
secular you cannot take 15 minutes for
the word of god
here's how we tend to live
there's a drawer in your bedroom
not a drawer what do you call those
things yeah
with a dresser okay sister
and they have drawers am i right
and the top drawer you have your hat
the middle drawer your silk stockings
your left drawer you have your shoes the
next drawer you have your shirts the
next ones socks the next one whatever
you know exactly where they are you can
find them with your eyes closed
you pull out one which has your socks
then you take a sock and you close that
drawer here's what we do we pull out the
sabbath drawer are you with me
spend some minutes in church when the
sun sets what do we do we slam it shut
and keep it shut
we don't open it again until next time
but if it's the sabbath drawer it is the
holy drawer are you following me
leave it open
which means it is entirely proper to
have a bible study on saturday night
two and a half people said amen
it is entirely proper to have a bible
study on a saturday night why because we
are people of the world
how many people say father
help me
in my life
daily
to make time for your life-giving word
connect to your right hand
let me ask you do you mean that
you really mean that
hands down
let's pray
father
by the word of the lord were the heavens
made
and the earth
you spoke
it was done
you commanded
it's the fast
it is by your word that christ dwells in
our hearts
please god
as we close this week of revival and
there is no revival without the word
as we close this revival father
let us commit ourselves to make time for
your word every day
because this is our life
this is our power to resist temptation
this is our defense against deception
and this is the wisdom that will allow
us to make decisions in these trying
times decisions that please heaven
for the decency
is man-made it's good but man-made
a spiritual life
which also includes decency is heaven
made
help us father to experience accept the
power of your word
to guide us
direct us to sanctify us as jesus prayed
sanctify them through thy truth without
the word there is no sanctification
and the bible says this is the will of
god even your sanctification therefore
the will of god must be the word of god
in our hearts
bless your sons
bless your daughters
bless all those who listen father
in person and online
and in this final prayer
work on the heart of that person father
who still needs to decide let him or her
make that decision to surrender the life
to christ to be baptized
it is humble pray father
increase our appetite for your word more
and more with each passing day
and save us at last father
when we will witness with our own eyes
the creation of the new heaven and the
new earth which will be done by the word
in jesus name we pray let god's people
say amen and amen